one month on from the killing of al
jazeera journalist shireen abu akley and
calls for an investigation into her
death continue to be ignored by the
israelis
the u.s state department has said it
wants an open independent israeli
investigation despite the fact that
shireen was an american citizen
but investigation or not it hasn't
dimmed the impact
she was born hours after shrine abu
aklay was killed by israeli soldiers
after shereen's death there was never
any doubt what her parents wanted to
call their newborn
shireen abu ah imran was born at midday
on may the 11th
i was in the hospital the night before
before i entered the operation room my
husband told me shireen had been killed
and he wanted to call our daughter that
i was shocked and sad shirin was killed
we were going to call our baby alma but
we didn't hesitate to change the name
at two weeks old she's already seen
israeli settlers attack a village and
while she won't remember this attack
it's likely she will see many incursions
like this in her life
the kind of witness that shireen the
journalist would seek out and report on
and she was doing just that in janine
when she was shot in the head on may 11
by israeli soldiers
on the day of her funeral israeli forces
stormed the procession and started to
beat mourners causing pallbearers to
nearly drop her casket
that didn't stop thousands of
palestinians from marching through
occupied east jerusalem to take part in
a funeral and burial
this is brazil university the most
prestigious educational institution in
palestine this is where shireen helped
the next generation of journalists
her loss has hit the campus hard the
university has announced a number of
ways to honour and remember her
including the shireen ab wakley
scholarship her best female journalist
shireen is an example
that needs to remain alive
for the students in order to continue
learning from and inspiring efron
from gaza to the occupied west bank
across palestine shrines killing is not
only shocked but united palestinians
here and abroad in grief
this is sharing abu arkhale's office is
now a temporary shrine to her almost
every day people are coming into this
office with floral arrangements and some
i have to say very touching artwork but
this isn't about her being a journalist
this is much more than that there's a
now common saying about sharing about
that she was a daughter of palestine
imran khan al jazeera ramallah